for this second week week two will be
taking you from the pretty
straightforward process of creating
images on a flatbed scanner to what you
probably expected in the first place
when you enrolled in our class using a
camera and lens to capture images of
your work in the lab will first take a
look at what kind of equipment you'll
need we'll look at specific lighting
next week and we'll go over the very
basics of making an image because this
course is about photographing certain
material with a certain scale we're
going to be very specific in our
suggestions for a camera and lens and
for other equipment these photographs
will be staged you have control you're
not going to wonder what the image will
look like after it's done you will see
your process and you're thinking as you
create the setup and light it and
compose it we're also going to review
the important issue of getting the right
exposure for our specific requirements
now we're assuming you already have some
basic knowledge of picture making and
we'll just be modifying what you all
hopefully already know if you're really
brand new to all of this you'll find
some useful websites on our resource
page so first your camera you don't need
a camera with all sorts of bells and
whistles you just need one which will
take various lenses and that will allow
you to change your ISO aperture and
shutter settings and most important one
that will create a large enough image
measured in file size that could be
submitted let's say for a publication or
even a cover submission you would
generally need for example about a 27
Meg file so something like 300 DPI for
an eight and a half by 11 cover so you
need a camera that will give you that
size image now for your lens you'll need
a 105 macro
lens this particular lens will allow you
to get close to your material or device
basically using macro photographic
techniques don't use enlarging filters
on a normal lens the quality of the
optics just doesn't compare to the
optics of a very fine macro lens you'll
also need a tripod and I suggest getting
a quick release mechanism so that you
can take your camera on and off the
tripod easily I'm not going to suggest a
copy stand which I see around many labs
using a copy stand where the camera is
placed only in one position really
limits your point of view and we don't
want to do that you'll see in our
discussion of point of view about having
the ability to move the camera around on
a tripod which not only slows you down
which is a good thing but it teaches you
to learn to see and encourages you to
look carefully at your material finally
I'm also suggesting that you use your
computer to decide on the various
settings for exposure you'll use this
software to make the right settings and
you'll store the images right onto your
computer not a card in your camera make
sure you get the right software for your
camera but for those of you who decide
not to use software you'll just have to
learn how to set all those settings
within your camera ok the best way to go
about learning all of this is to make a
picture so we'll work with a device
you've seen before the inside of a music
box